c'était furtif imperceptible même pour
certains mais la neige est tombée ce
matin quelques flocons qui n'ont pas
résisté à des températures encore trop
douce pour qu'elle tienne
regardez ces images des flocons sur les
trottoirs de romorantin loir-et-cher
il était temps l'hiver arrive enfin lui
qui a enregistré des records de chaleur
pas seulement en france mais dans le
monde va s'installer peu à peu moins de
aujourd'hui météo france prévoit -4 ce
week-end en touraine la neige et le
verglas pourrait arriver dans les jours
qui suivent reportage en boîte ronde a
dévié sur le marché d'amboise les fruits
les légumes les clients et les
commerçants ont fait l'expérience du
froid de la neige et de la pluie en une
matinée
sylvie la poissonnière se réchauffe les
mains contre la bassine d'eau chaude une
bassine qui lui servira en fin de marché
à nettoyer les outils sans se geler un
peu plus les mains on a vu de la gelée
ce matin c'était déjà verglacée ce matin
donc on a vu les sableuses de ce matin à
4h30 et puis dans la matinée on a vu la
neige arrivée voilà sur la tourelle donc
finalement la neige c'était plutôt que
ce sera doux si c'est oui voilà malgré
le froid c'était que sa radio 6 et 7
productrice de lait qui réalise aussi
des confitures maison à montreuil en
touraine a été de son côté un peu
surprise par la fraîcheur matinale les
degrés en moins sûr
sur le thermomètre bon ça surprend un
peu parce qu'on s'était habitué à avoir
un temps bien bien clément et puis voilà
c'est arrivé quand même non maintenant
il faut se résoudre à mettre les
pull-overs les grosses doudounes et la
grosse doudoune dominique va pouvoir la
garder pour préparer le marché de
dimanche car le froid va persister durée
au fil des journées
ce qui nous attend pour ce week-end est
ce qu'on n'a pas connue depuis déjà un
certain temps c'est du froid du froid
ont somme toute rien d'extraordinaire
pour cette saison mais quand même des
gelées autour de - 2 - 3 en tête même
plus basses encore dimanche matin ce
sera sûrement la nuit la plus froide à
météo france
on reste prudent pour les prévisions de
lundi mais l'association de
perturbations et de froid pourrait mener
au verglas à la neige et nous plonger
pour de bon dans l'hiver